this movie lives or dies on the
chemistry between you and Emery Cohen
and you and domhnall gleeson we have to
feel like this is a real battle in her
mind and we do we you know don't see she
was cast first and then Donal was second
and they're both actors in very
different ways that I had wanted to work
with really really strongly and Toni
took a lot longer to find and that may
be because my expertise is in Ireland in
England and it took a while to find
somebody who had the right degree of
masculinity on the one hand we
believably an italian-american plumber
in the 50s but who also was sweet and
who didn't mind you I wanted an act it
was it would be egoless enough to spot
that she's slightly out of his league
and then he worships her and it's okay
that he's not gonna be the cool kid you
know that and that's a very particular
task and it's a big ask of a lot of
young actress because they tend to be
happier working sometimes with darker
material and Emory had done a lot of
dark material but he did a reading put
himself on tape which was one of those
tapes auditions which is fair to say we
all looked at and went there's our guy
so and from there then there's all
process of actually getting him to the
roles and directing and everything but
you know and
but that was how they were cast so it
wasn't it was really about cast the
right actor and and the chemistry will
take care of itself which it really did
we also through that process you know
because names come up and it was it was
really about finding that right person
who was going to that it was getting the
film would work with that sort of
triangle because it wasn't worth just
sort of shoehorning the wrong person and
so that was also very it was just like
we should just kind of go for go for
broke and not worry but you know just
get the right actors so every time
anyone on this film writes a letter
reads a letter opens a letter I lose it
there is just it I don't know it's a
letter yeah I didn't like that
but I don't know if you're like piping
in tear gas at every moment that there's
a letter being written but it was is it
the music is what's what's the secret
they're in putting it all together and
how did you calibrate so that you would
want the audience to feel something
without going overboard I think it's a
beautiful score by Michael Brooke um but
I think the music for me is a subtle
score can only support what's going on
on the screen I mean it can't generate
an emotion all right well it can pump up
a false emotion as we know and often
does but you know when we were cutting
this film we used very very very little
music on it because we never wanted to
create false effects whether it wanted
it to work to distill it down to the
emotional essence and then we would
support it with what we needed to
support it later
the answers in front of you I mean it's
in her face is when she looks at that
letter in the bedroom the first one and
when she's reading it in the diner the
next day and rereading and then looks at
herself in the mirror you know that's it
there it's it's it's um an ability to
access a rawness and a vulnerability and
Saoirse was very close to those emotions
herself having moved away from home and
the year before we shot and it's fair to
say they were very available to you on
set in a way that was quite immediate so
it's it's not quite fair to say there
was no acting and involved was beautiful
acting involved but it was acting that
was very close to where her head and her
heart were and on that set every day and
then you can come in with everything
else rhyme and with you know Eve belong
a great cameraman responded and he's I
think he's a great cameraman partly
because he loves faces and whatever
Syria would do in a take he'd respond
organically to it so that's how those
moments all work I also love all of the
boarding house dinner scenes there
there's they're so fun and the you just
you just get a smile on your face
whenever there's an establishing shot of
all of those girls it and Julie Walters
sitting there what were those like to
film did you film them all in the same
week or two did you scatter them
throughout the week or do what you think
our budget
I mean we must have shot the all of the
scenes in four days three days yes less
three days I think to do everything
there and it was an it was an absolute
honor to actually be in so many sayings
that just consist of women to just be
sitting around a table yeah you don't
say yes we never say it and to see and
to me this is the real heart of this
film more than anything and is that one
woman is kind to another and helps her
to grow and to become the person that
she can be um and so to have these
scenes with Julie Walters who I have
grown up watching in everything she's in
everything home she is she I've grown
I've grown up watching her on TV and
film she's so wonderful and she's so
humble and is very much just another not
just but she's another one of the actors
and and everyone was so funny and
touching and even you know in contrast
to all of these great funny scenes that
we have to then have NJ who plays Sheila
do that gorgeous that the saying in the
bathroom where she talks about her
husband you know and again it's just her
she doesn't she doesn't come along to a
leash and go well here's what you can
learn from me kid she's like she's just
sharing her experience and that in turn
helps a little start to grow and kind of
and have a clearer perspective on
ourselves and her own situation and I
know that I really experienced when I
moved away and the the really special
bond that you have with the women in
your life you know when you're growing
up and you're sort of figuring out where
you stand in the adult world when it
comes to yourself and work and
relationships and everything else and it
was the women that I had that it is the
women that I have in my life that um
that I leaned on and
to actually be able to celebrate that in
a film female kind of bonding was
amazing
so most of what we see on the screen is
Montreal doubling for Brooklyn but you
have you had a couple days where you
actually shot in Brooklyn what was most
important for you to achieve in that
limited time and what was it like for
you to actually be in the borough for
those couple days well we we had a lot
to do is the answer in two days which
was to convince everybody that the whole
thing had been shot in New York and we
did we did Coney Island obviously cuz
nothing doubles for Coney Island we did
the whole of the exterior on the
brownstone streets and it was to try and
maximize as much feeling because we had
shot at all and location in Ireland and
it really goes into the bones of the
film when you do it on location so it
was quite a particular homecoming for
you isn't it I mean you were born in New
York City we should I was born in the
Bronx obviously I have to say to finish
the film in Brooklyn or we shot on in
Coney Island the first area two days
shot in Coney Island the first day we
were all knackered at that stage we you
know every single day we were doing two
to three big scenes and and I remember
once a and actually when aylesh is kind
of contemplating going home and her and
Tony go to the restaurant where they had
their first date and I'm leaning on them
and everything that you know that was a
obviously a very big part of the story
and and it was we were anxious about
Emory and I and we started shooting that
at like 12 o'clock at night after doing
so many other things that day so by the
time we got to broke them and shot on
Clinton Street and shot outside the
brownstones it was just me and Emory for
the whole day and and I mean we had so
many different setups to finish it there
and as John says to have a homecoming
and again like Ailish and at that stage
we had gone full circle
had gone full circle and we started out
in Ireland and we were all there
together and and to finish it off we're
in the place that really makes her who
she is was was incredibly special I
think my mom came in for as well and it
was our birthday and and she came over
and she spent the last couple of days
with me and to have her there when we
when we're at this film that just she
she knew how how much I cared about it
you know so to have her there was
incredibly special